The Joe Rogan Experience with grush I
think
here's my take on it I think he believes
what he's saying right I think he has
gone out there I think I'm Legit like he
was a whatever 14-year veteran of
military and and
National reconnaissance office and
and I think he went out and he talked to
enough people
and he
um
he believes it I don't think he's out
there like spinning a yarn and is
worried that now he's gotten over his
skis and he's said you know too many
things and now but
um
I I don't I don't know I don't I don't
feel like it's tidy and maybe the
difference between us is
I spent you know a lot of time with the
government and
um the government is is uh
is sometimes can be really really uh
dysfunctional and I just it goes back to
Keeping a Secret the idea that they
could have this this what essentially is
a covert action campaign you know to
spread this information about what they
actually know right when the easier
thing to do is just to have the program
you know if if again if it's it's the US
government's you know development of
Technology right and and we're doing
this to have the program and just keep
your app shut about it not go for a
disinformation campaign not try to muddy
The Waters by doing this because in a
sense you're just creating more
conversation around it you're creating
you know now there's a little bit of a
you know movement within Congress to say
we have to do this now we have to so
they're going to look perhaps for a
misappropriation of funds right because
they're not going to pursue like the UAP
issue necessarily right but but they
might be interested in pursuing the
misappropriation of funds so if you're
running a program if it if it didn't
again going back to the idea that it's a
US government if you're running a
program that's the last thing you want
to do is because you've you're doing
this program to avoid government
oversight you're not going to create you
know this alternative narrative that you
know could generate the sort of
publicity or the conversation
particularly up on Capitol Hill that
causes them to then start looking and
saying well where is money being spent
right right because there is a trail
there and that could cause a problem
um so
yeah
um what so what are your instincts
when you look at it if I'm I'm looking
at I'm saying something's wrong it seems
like [__] what are your instincts
um
yeah I think
uh
I would like to stay you know I don't
think we're going to get there but my
instinct is to say how do we solve the
how do we solve this or how do we how do
we come to some sort of uh logical
resolution as opposed to saying what is
it right off the bat my instinct is to
say all right if the all domain
anomalous or anomaly resolution office
has 800 cases then tell us what those
800 cases are let's work our way through
them or have a little bit more
transparency about working through those
cases again you'll probably Whittle them
down right to when we were doing black
files and we were going around talking
to people about you know various
sightings and things you basically just
crossing things off going okay that was
this that was this this you know you
find some pretty mundane answers you
know but you Whittle it down to maybe
one or two things that you can't explain
and then you can investigate those and
say okay all right let's let's dig
further on these but right now it's just
like all over the map and they've got so
many cases and they just kind of lump it
all together
um are they doing that to obfuscate and
create you know this this this this this
situation where it does seem like
[__] and
I again I I I don't know but I think
um I'm not willing to shut the door on
saying that that those handful of those
few sightings that where we do have
technical data we've got video we got
you know radar lock we got we got gun
camera footage whatever it may be that
can't be explained I'm not willing to
close the door and say well it's you
know you know is it because who knows
maybe China's doing the same thing you
know oh we're leading the Hypersonic
race right now great but they've got
another program you know and they're
responsible for the Tic Tac right so we
we have to pursue it and if that leads
us to the doorstep that says oh that's a
U.S government program and they've
developed a technology okay you know
fine but you know I realized that you
know I I just I'm not willing to close
the door on saying it could be something
else could be otherworldly right because
I just I just it could be it could be I
just don't there is who knows that
problem the infinite nature of space
which seems to actually be getting
bigger yeah there was a good way of
putting it that that uh uh my wife who's
uh a hell of a lot smarter than I am
um try to explain it to me and I kept
looking like this and but she had heard
a she had heard a program at one point
where the the person explained it like
okay imagine how vast the ocean is right
and you know how you you we've explored
the ocean but then you look at space and
how immense it is right compared to the
ocean right right the amount that we've
explored in space right is equivalent to
like a wine glass full of ocean water
right so you take a wine glass full
ocean water you look at it you go ah
there's nothing there right you know
there's all those life forms there's all
all those fish in the sea it's kind of
like and then you know you think about
space and you think about what we know
and what we don't know and how we
imagine like our limited capacity to
imagine what life outside of Earth could
look like right so it yeah
but when you hear talk of like crashed
retrieval programs
yeah
that that keeps taking me back and is
you know to this this whole idea of
uh if there was a crash retrieval and
reverse engineering program like David
grush talked about and had been in
existence for decades
um
somebody would have [__] opened their
Yap and talked about it I think
other than bobbles are and they would
have had some better specifics right I
mean that's always the thing that's it's
always where it falls down well I
haven't seen it but I talked to somebody
who knows that it exists right and I
think maybe it's because we're human
we're programmed that actually want
physical evidence yeah right we want to
actually see it before we believe it
um but you know that that really hasn't
happened yet what's one of the things
that's fascinating is the narrative has
shifted so wildly from it's completely
Preposterous to Credible people like
David fravor and Ryan Graves and all
these different people that are talking
about multiple sightings things that
completely defy our understanding of
what a vehicle is capable of doing
hovering completely Motionless in 120
knot winds all the the whole you know
whatever that thing is the the cube
inside of sphere that they keep seeing
over and over again right almost hit one
of the aircraft yeah yeah and what the
[__] is that yeah and then they land so
I think you know one of the good
developments out of all of this and one
of the things that may eventually lead
to transparency right because it will it
will provide an Avenue for these
sightings whether it's commercial or
military Pilots as an example to report
it right and to be more and and for the
government to take it perhaps you know
again it depends on what it's a big
conspiracy or not to um to investigate
in a more logical manner in in a more
detailed manner so I I think just again
the sheer act that we're talking about
it
which then takes me back to the idea
that you know if you're running a secret
program you don't want people talking
about it so you're not going to muddy
the waters with a false narrative if you
don't have to right you know if your
concerned is that someone's getting
close to the truth and you got to do
okay then maybe so but
um you know do you think it's also
possible that there are patriots that do
think that the American public deserves
to know about this information and they
have been sitting on it for a long time
um
the people like David rush and all these
various people that are coming out and
more apparently are wanting to come out
yeah well interesting thing with
gracious look he's he said so during the
hearing right he said I can't talk about
that I could talk about it in a skiff
right and it's sensitive uh secure uh
environment all right well if I'm you
know one of the people on on that
subcommittee I'm gonna say you know what
uh to my staff schedule uh you know a
skiff meeting with Grouch get them in
here and let's you know have them talk
at a classified [__] right
um so that would be the next logical
step in all of this have they done that
yet I I don't know I mean it's
you know when he said I could talk to
you about it and Skip as have people
taken them up on that well I'd I'd you
know you would have to ask him no I
wouldn't right and they wouldn't tell
anything and they wouldn't and they
wouldn't tell them in there they're in
lies part of the problem because if he
sits there and but if he sits in the
skiff and and continues to kind of say
well like you know okay I know you guys
aren't clear to hear this and I can't
tell you all right then you got to start
questioning you know
what he's actually got or what he what
he knows for sure rather than just
having this this you know witness
interviews and sort of second-hand
information but I am I'm much more I
guess the point is I'm much more
interested in the direct sightings than
uh witness interviews right right and
the thing about him is he's not really a
witness
where he hasn't had any personal
encounters with anything right he hasn't
had personal encounter with a craft he
hasn't seen a retrieved craft he hasn't
seen the biological entities these are
all just programs that he's been made
aware of that he felt like people needed
to know about
yeah and that's the narrative and again
not to disparage anybody right I mean
he's you know if in fact
um you know uh somebody leaked his
medical records which it looks like you
know did happen right then that's that
you know that's that's pretty [__]
right somebody needs to figure out what
the hell is happening yes the
information from grush who said he was
unable to discuss specifics on what he
told the pentagon's Watchdog arm
lawmakers want to sit down with the
former official in a sensitive
compartmented information facility a
skiff to get additional information from
him the group has been blocked however
by officials that have informed them
that grush doesn't currently have
security clearance to discuss the issues
in a skiff according to Burchette we
think that we'll get there eventually
it's just frustrating I'm ready to go in
the American public are ready to go he
said Luna argued that the skiff with
grush could help lawmakers better
understand the type of legislation they
need to write regarding uaps she said
she supports legislative relation that
would declassify information on the
phenomenon so there seems to be some
issue of secrecy and what what's
possible to discuss or what's legal to
discuss well but yeah look the
government casts a very wide net when
you're talking about classified
information right the government has
over classified information for decades
and decades right and you've got secret
top secret you know code word you know
and
you know they they tend to just Hoover
everything up and classify it right and
and then it takes [__] forever right
to go through that process of
declassification and because nobody
wants to put their neck out at that
point and say yeah let's declassify this
right once it's once it's in that pot
um so but the question is great you know
you're saying you know you can talk
about in a skiff well damn that's the
next that that's what the subcommittee
should be doing that's their job right
if they're curious right and if they're
sincere about trying to get to the
bottom of this and that's theoretically
their job then they should because again
going back to the main thing and people
can say well why are you wasting your
time on this but you can always Circle
back to the Top Line which is it's for
national security purposes we want to
know what the hell's going on right and
and you know if so
yeah we'll see I guess that's the that's
the question that should be thrown at
grush or should be thrown at the
subcommittee members I'm also shocked at
how few people care
I feel like people are so overloaded
with information today because of social
media and because of the new cycle
you're just people are so overloaded
with information that this barely
registered on people other than UFO nuts
yeah yeah I mean there was a there was a
surprising amount I thought anyway of of
sort of mainstream media coverage it
wasn't particularly uh deep right it
just kind of covered okay it was a
hearing and I think they did it because
it's like it's UFOs or uaps right and so
you know they knew they'd get some
clicks on it if they were putting it
online or whatever and and
they didn't pursue it you know like has
been any I haven't seen any stories that
talked about the follow-up around with
Crush
um there were a couple of stories
talking about the you know the fact that
perhaps his medical records were leaked
you know and the medical records showed
what that he had some sort of a
psychiatric condition
that he had an event or something like
that PTSD I think you know some suicidal
depression issues standing stuff with
military veteran yeah yeah yeah he had
been he had done his time in Afghanistan
right and so
um that doesn't yeah it means nothing
and except for the fact that it
shouldn't be out there right those
records should be damn well private well
not only that isn't that what we want
why don't you shut your little Dinger
off there fella is that is that me going
to you yeah that's why your phone rings
yeah yeah you've got to learn how to use
that little switch on the side
um but thank you for my idea isn't that
what you want from I mean that's the
whole purpose of providing these
services for veterans that when they do
have suicidal suicidal thoughts and they
are struggling with PTSD that they get
help I mean the the idea that they're
shaming him and saying that his report
is not credible because of this seems
ridiculous yeah it's totally [__]
yeah and and and he said he he's come
out since he said look I did seek help I
you know I'm in a better place
um and he was happy that people were
talking about they should be talking
about yeah look it's we we lose a
shocking number for veterans to Suicide
right and it's disgusting that we don't
you know that the government doesn't
work harder at this right and spend more
effort you know I know a couple of
people who do amazingly good work at the
VA in terms of counselors right they're
not managers they're not Executives they
work with the veterans every day right
and it's incredible what they do but
overall as a government our
our assistance right to Veterans
um I mean look at the number of homeless
situations it's it's it's pathetic and
so when he talks about it
um it's it's good that he's talking
about it right I think that that
transparency helps and and he clearly
views it that way too and he said look I
don't have any problem with with
discussing it but we should be concerned
by the fact that you know somehow his
medical records were were put out there
and then you know some people will look
at that and go well is that the
government's effort to discredit them
you know or is that or or is that
somebody's effort to discredit them um I
don't know why anybody else would why
would you do that